Democrats in six states head to the
primaries today and polling shows Joe
Biden might blow Bernie Sanders out of
the water within a matter of hours we
will examine the latest data on Joe's
chances in November then pundits on all
sides attack the president for his
response to the flu manciu outbreak but
a very important group much more
important than the chattering class
thinks President Trump is doing just
fine
finally a woman asks slate if she should
tell her husband to stop sleeping with
his girlfriend to stop corona virus from
spreading to her mother we will break
down this woman's problems and our
culture's problems both biological and
social all that and more on Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Knowles
show
[Music]
big primaries coming up today we're
gonna find out maybe who the Democrat
nominee is we've got Michigan Washington
Missouri Mississippi Idaho North Derek
Dakota and Democrats abroad Democrats
abroad is a state you know the left
complains about the right wing in this
country colluding with foreign entities
they actually have a completely separate
primary among the Democrats for
Democrats who happen to be living
overseas we will get to the breakdowns
in those states what it's looking like
and how Bernie Sanders just totally
collapsed first I've got to thank our
friends over at Ashford University you
know sometimes when you're working it is
really gonna help you out to go back to
school maybe you want to add some skills
that you don't have that you need in
your career maybe you just want to learn
something but it's hard to go back to
school when you're working and that's
why I recommend Ashford University
Ashford University's online bachelor's
and master's programs allow you to learn
at your own pace you can study wherever
you're the most comfortable learning
whether that's a sitting at the table at
a desk or lying in bed Ashford
University's six-week long courses allow
you to take one course at a time being
enrolled in one class at Ashford means
you are considered a full time student
the yealt the SAT GRE GMAT other
standardized test scores are not
required for enrolling at Ashford
Ashford University is fully accredited
by the W ASC senior college and
university commissioned get on the road
to earning your degree and making your
dream job a reality and a role now by
going to Ashford dot edu / Knowles KO
wles that's Ashford edu / Knowles kena
wles to start your degree today Ashford
uh TD u / Knowles so Michigan Washington
Missouri Mississippi Idaho North Dakota
and all those various Democrats living
abroad right now the only states that
Sanders is projected to win are
Washington also known as little Wuhan
these days
and Democrats abroad which is not a
state and even there Bernie is only up
by a very small margin for Democrats
abroad it's about 1.4 percent and in
Washington it's about 0.5 percent so
that could go anyway how did the how did
the other polls break down so the key
states to look at here are Missouri
Mississippi and Michigan according to
data for progress Missouri Missouri
right now in in in 2016 Hillary won
Missouri by 2000 votes out of six
hundred twenty three thousand votes
total cast so Bernie Sanders could make
a huge play here in Missouri except he's
getting blown out of the water right now
Joe Biden has 62 points he's up thirty
points on Bernie Sanders who's down at
thirty-two then Liz Warren has four even
though she's not in the race anymore and
Gabbard who is in the race but the
mainstream media don't want to admit
that she is she's down at two so Biden
absolutely crushing it in Missouri right
now how about Mississippi in Mississippi
Hillary did very very well Bernie didn't
do well and it looks like the same is
going to hold true Joe Biden up 55
points eight Mississippi 77 to 22 and
Gabbard gets one point and then Michigan
all-important Michigan Michigan which
may decide the general election in
November in 2016 Bernie beat Hillary in
Michigan so Bernie's certainly going to
win in 2020 right not according to the
Detroit Free Press Detroit Free Press
currently has Joe Biden at 51% Bernie is
all the way down at 27 then other gets 9
and declined to answer the question gets
13 way off beat I mean Biden is almost
double Bernie right now according to
Detroit Free Press that's not just one
poll on Mitchell research also shows in
Michigan Biden is at 54% Bernie is at 33
percent so Biden could have a great
night I mean we were talking about two
weeks ago how Bernie was running away
with the nomination we're they were
going to nominate us so
chillest in 2020 and then we the
Conservatives were just absolutely going
to trounce him and win 57 states plus
American Samoa plus the people abroad
and plus Greenland and that doesn't look
like it's going to happen now I mean Joe
Biden really seems to have consolidated
that was the deciding factor Biden was
always at the top of the polls then
there was a question about his
electability so he dropped very quickly
then the question about his electability
went in his favor in South Carolina he
shot back up very quickly the
electability question is a huge factor
in in Biden's case it's the only factor
and it's why you could see huge swings
like that in the analysis so what does
this mean for Trump according to a
firehouse optimist poll Trump does
better against Bernie than he does
against Biden duh I've been telling you
that the whole time if you're running
against a guy who honeymooned in the
Soviet Union and who says nice things
about Fidel Castro
you're probably gonna do pretty well in
America you're definitely gonna do very
well in Florida what's important to note
here though because what the Democrats
keep telling us is actually what some
Republicans keep telling us too is look
when when you go up against Biden in
November Trump is gonna have a really
hard time
Biden's gonna win if the coronavirus tax
the economy Biden's gonna saunter over
to the White House no problem the
polling shows Biden is definitely
tougher however in a head-to-head
matchup Trump still beats Biden in all
the most important states so the way
that the mainstream media the way that
the Democrats are trying to convince you
that Biden is gonna win and Trump is
going to lose is they only show you
national elections national elections
don't matter
popular vote doesn't matter that's not
how we choose the president what matters
are people in those states Michigan
Pennsylvania Wisconsin Ohio right the
the states that are actually going to
deter Florida they're gonna determine
the election that's where Trump has to
be winning and head-to-head right now
Trump is winning even against Joe Biden
and by the way Joe but it's not like Joe
Biden's gonna get better throughout this
campaign if anything day by day we're
seeing Joe Biden fall apart
is absolutely collapsing before our eyes
that might just be because there's a lot
of pressure on these campaigns might be
because they're physically just daunting
they're exhausting we could now I think
have a regular segment on this show
which is what jumbled nonsense came out
of Joe Biden's mouth today and we've
done it every single day we have to do
it every day guys every day
there's more to look at so we got two
new entries for today yesterday we saw
Joe forget his boss's name twice and
then his own name once today we see that
he forgets who controls the House of
Representatives areas we're gonna win
back the house
we're except we won back the house
already two years ago but I wasn't
paying attention then and I don't anyway
I'm getting confused look taken in
isolation any of these little gaffes are
easy enough to make look I do it on this
show I confuse Bernie and Biden
sometimes I say Bernie's I meant to say
Biden sorry Biden I meant to say Bernie
right these things happen I hopefully
I'm not just becoming like you know Joe
Biden myself that would that would not
be good at all
but when they happen multiple times a
day every single day two degrees from
you know you kind of forgot who controls
the House of Representatives - you
forgot your own name that is not a good
look and the next gaffe Joe made
yesterday really should have Democrats
worried we'll get to that in a second
first I got to thank our friends over at
LifeLock speaking of not remembering who
you are
identity theft is very scary and you
don't want it to happen especially this
time of year during tax season what do
you do you send all over the internet
your name your social security number a
lot of valuable information about you
right it gets sent all around criminals
can steal that information from your
device's and sell it on the dark web or
use it to commit identity theft you
won't even know it as it's happening to
help prevent this you need life lock the
number one most recognized brand in
identity theft protection life lock
monitors for uses
of your personal info it alerts you to
possible suspicious activity and if you
become a victim of identity theft a
dedicated identity restoration
specialist will work to fix it join
right now you can save up to 25% off
your first year just go to LifeLock
dot-com slash Knowles kano wles do it
now especially this time of year you
will not regret it
LifeLock of the people that I trust
LifeLock dot-com / Knowles for 25
percent off
so if ok you forgot who controls deaths
of representatives ok he forgot his
boss's name ok he forgot his own name in
one clip from the same same speech
yesterday at Joe Biden was campaigning
with Cory Booker he seemed to have words
just fail him like he was making sounds
but they were not coherent words and he
went on this was what was the most kind
of scary about it he went on as though
he was making a sense but the words
didn't mean anything here is what could
anybody look I know people are in the
chat box right now and live could
anybody try to tell me what he just said
there if you look at Cory Booker's
standing behind him it was Cory Booker
endorsed Joe Biden yesterday
Cory when when Biden starts to ramble
like that you see his eyes kind of widen
up because what he looks away he's like
looking it looks down a little bit it's
a gosh what the heck did I do
why why I'm Spartacus I was supposed to
be the president so now to add more
evidence to the heaping pile that Joe
Biden has not fit to become President
Joe Biden isn't now reportedly asking
that he not even stand for the next
debate we'll get into what that means in
a second first let's take question from
a listener from jhi Michael do you think
Biden might ask Hillary to be as VP I
don't know you think Biden's got a death
wish you think that guy's trying to get
suicided all right sleepy Joe might be
slippin but he's not that dumb what a
maniac would do that no I don't think
you will but Hillary's past her prime I
don't think she has interest in being VP
she was the Secretary of State the the
only the only way that she would want to
be VP is if she thought there were a
good chance of becoming president which
I guess in this presidential field is
pretty high but I think the only man who
would ask Hillary to be VP would have a
have a real death wish the seated debate
look I'm just reporting rumors here
folks I don't know I wasn't on the phone
call but there was a phone call with CNN
hosting the next next debate it's with
the Biden camp and the Bernie camp the
CNN moderators the CNN executives said
that for this debate instead of standing
at a podium like normal people at a
presidential debate let's just have
these two men sit in chairs not even on
stools in chairs so they're more
comfortable why because they're super
duper old you know they're four
political standards they are certainly
past their prime and Bernie Sanders
pushed back on this reportedly so Bernie
doesn't want to sit he wants to stand he
wants to show that he's vigorous
especially after he just had a heart
attack the Biden camp is denying that
they asked for a seated debate but
they're also not pushing back on it very
much so it could be a couple things it
could be that the CNN executives just
said look these two guys cannot possibly
stand up this long one is 77 one is 78
they've been on the campaign trail now
forever one of them just had a heart
attack one of them can't form an English
sentence and so let's just guy just give
them chairs it's like elder abuse over
here that's one option or the other
possibility is just that the Biden
campaign requested it because they know
that the guy is slipping more and more
each day
they're also by the way they're both in
the most at-risk category for the
coronavirus maybe you think people are
overreacting to coronavirus maybe you
think people the media are blowing it
out of proportion okay but it is the
case that people are self-quarantine in
right now my podcast co-host
ted cruz's self-quarantine a number of
congressmen are right so people are
taking it seriously people are canceling
conferences people are doing a whole lot
of stuff so I wouldn't be surprised if
the Biden and Bernie campaigns start to
change their reaction they are very much
at risk here this is a big
miscalculation on the Democrats part
that first will get to a listener
response from tea be pretty sure Biden
said khofifah you know that's what it
was it's hard to tell I it's one of
those words when you read it it's so
obvious but when you hear a presidential
candidate articulating it with his words
that that's why I didn't get it you're
right Kofi Fay despite all the negative
press he said cough F a so big
miscalculation the Democrats if they
want to show that they're really ready
for Trump in November they should not
have these two candidates sitting down
it will look horrible if they can they
should have these two candidates run a
marathon they should have been running
down San Vicente in Los Angeles over the
weekend okay in times of uncertainty
people want a vigorous president think
about the uncertainty or you've got the
market tanking you've got this virus
that seems like not the end of the world
but who knows we don't really know a
whole lot about the virus we'll get to
that in a moment we'll get to Trump's
response to it but in that time of
uncertainty you know who you don't want
to be President a guy who who can't
speak or a guy who can't stand or a guy
who is frail and elderly you just don't
want it I mean you want why is elder
statesman ship sir but you you want a
guy who can actually do the job but
those are the choices so we saw
yesterday Hillary Clinton is not yet
ready to endorse she's getting ready to
go Epstein Joe Biden I'm joking I'm
kidding
but she's still not she's not going to
endorse him even though she doesn't like
Bernie Sanders she's now going to put
her support behind Joe
the only other holdout here would seem
to be Nancy Pelosi and Nancy Pelosi
raises some serious questions about
who's going to get this nomination we'll
get to that in one second first I got to
thank our friends over at ring what is
ring to ring keeps neighborhoods safer
gives you
action at every corner and helps you
create custom affordable security for
your home range video doorbells let you
answer the door and check in on your
home anytime anywhere whether you're at
the office whether you're in your
bedroom whether you're on a beach
somewhere rings full home security
systems give you everything you need to
protect your family pets and property
with rings outdoor security cameras you
can check in on every part of your house
so you'll never miss a moment it's
really good you know I'm on the road a
lot and sweet a little lease is pretty
good with a gun but I like to know that
I can be safe you can receive
notifications on your phone tablet or PC
when people come onto your property see
hear and speak to the visitors in real
time get the special offer right now on
the ring welcome kit when you go to ring
comm slash knowles canada wles that
includes ring video doorbell two-inch
i'm pro it's all you need to start
building custom security for your home
today ring comm slash knowles ring comm
slash knowles okay so one person here
other than hillary one person who's not
willing to endorse jo just yet that
would be the speaker of the house one of
the leaders of the Democratic Party
Nancy Pelosi who said she has isn't
ready to endorse Joe because she usually
just wants to vote for a woman Cara and
that's just so we're gonna find them and
the Congress in the country and in the
court of law to preserve all that that
means the live stage the the progress
made and then working together to take
the best that any of us has to offer to
go down that path but it's no reflection
point a lot of support for president
United States I'll just say just
generally I usually always cast my vote
for a woman
[Music]
just generally by the way I love I love
how the left gets away with these kind
of categorical statements but the right
cannot I love how women can get away
with these categorical statements but
men cannot I lied so always that I guess
that's left is imrat if they didn't have
double standards they'd have no
standards at all imagine if I came out
there and said Michael who are you gonna
support for presidents you know I don't
know
I haven't decided yet but a man of
definitely a man I vote for men I don't
I don't vote for women I just think men
are better at it and women they're just
not so I vote for men and then you
deploy say well Michael that's so brave
that's so brave of you but of course she
gets away with it of course it's a
double standard it's kind of silly even
to to complain about it that's just the
way politics goes the reason that I
think policies line here is interesting
is because there are some people in this
country who have not given out hope that
Hillary Clinton could somehow still win
this thing now that might become much
more difficult after tonight all right
we got these six states coming up if Joe
Biden really blows it out of the water
and looks like he's going to do well in
the future states too then the odds of a
brokered convention decreased
significantly if there were a brokered
convention we don't see these very often
you could walk in there and Hillary
Clinton could be the nominee is that
likely no could it happen yes Mike
Bloomberg could be the nominee for
goodness sake that'd be hilarious
instead probably Joe Biden's gonna walk
away with this but they're not ready
just yet the whole Democratic
establishment is coalescing here few
holdouts we'll see if Joe Biden can put
that to rest tonight the the big
question in the election probably will
not be the brokered convention and
Hillary coming in and abstaining
everybody and stealing the nomination
probably a big question at least for the
next couple months is going to be this
woo flu this coronavirus what do we know
about it people are getting a lot of
different information about it I've
spoken to friends who are expert in this
field who say really we need to
seriously it's not being blown out of
proportion pay attention take care of
yourself wash your hands I've also heard
from people who say yeah it's not a big
deal don't worry about it calm down
there are some weird features of the Wu
flute so do you know what the average
age of Wu Han virus death is the average
age 80 years old 80 that's pretty that's
like how old do people live the average
life expectancy is what 78 I believe
it's a little higher for women a little
bit lower for men so this seems to be
really affecting people who are already
in a weakened condition the other weird
thing about it and it's related to that
fact is kids don't get it as far as I
can tell there have been no serious
cases of the Wu Han virus among children
the kids who have gotten it have shown
very very mild systems like this could
be a generational disease this is like
Revenge of the Zoomers or whatever the
generation after the Zoomers is against
the Boomers we don't know very much
about it so I'm not going to pretend
that we've got all the answers here
everything we're seeing shows that other
public health crises have been deadlier
and deadlier to more people so I think
about the swine flu which I actually had
it in college I was quarantined for it I
wasn't able to go out for two weeks
it wasn't nasty flu and a lot of people
died from I think was at the low end
12,500 might have been as high as 15,000
people in the United States died from
swine flu around the world it was
200,000 people died from it but did we
hear a whole lot about that now not
really I mean that happened under Barack
Obama did we hear that you know this was
going to destroy the economy I guess in
those days during the early Obama days
the economy was already destroyed but it
just didn't seem to be such a big
sensation in the mainstream media if it
had been a Republican president probably
it would have been what about Ebola you
know Ebola much much more deadly SARS
remember SARS death rate on SARS was 10
percent for people over 60 was 50-plus
percent okay so those were much much
deadlier than this that's encouraging
still we need to be careful that's
all I can give you on the biological or
medical front the public health front
because we just don't know we're have to
wait and see we get new information
every day the political aspect is a
little easier to take a look at here and
that I think is where a lot of people in
the mainstream media are focusing their
efforts so the question is has Trump
doing
how has the Trump response been this guy
is catching flack from all sides
everybody is dissatisfied with his
response except for one group and that
one group really matters so what's he
done he appointed his number two to lead
the task force to take care of it right
he put the vice-president of the United
States in charge of it that shows he's
taking it seriously
he very early on banned travel from
at-risk countries for coronavirus good
thing proactive measure he was called a
racist at the time as he always is but
it was a smart thing to do so far in the
United States how many cases do we have
12,500 like with swine flu no it's
actually 700 cases so far how many
deaths 26 deaths all right that
comparison shows we're doing relatively
okay now there is a criticism of Trump
that he's even mentioning statistics
like that
it's the tweets right it's always they
complain about the tweets it's true
president Trump yesterday tweeted at he
said look we've only had 22 deaths think
about that compared to other public
health crises there is a criticism here
that the president shouldn't be
mentioning those sort of statistics you
know it is I think probably unseemly of
the President to downplay it like that
you don't want your president to say
poof we made it out fine only 26 people
dead right you want from your president
a guy just seemed to be somber and sort
of mourning every single death I get
that I get that however the criticism of
the chattering class on the
administration's response here is not
representative of the rest of the
country that's not nearly my uninformed
opinion that's not just my intuition you
don't have to take my word for it we
have polling to gauge exactly what
people think and despite what the
pundits say on the on the left and on
the right
despite everybody criticizing Trump's
response the voters are not there is a
poll out from firehouse optimist it
pulls people in Michigan Wisconsin and
Pennsylvania so you're talking about
three of the most important states in
2020 representative of who's going to
decide this election a majority of
likely voters in all three states are
very or somewhat concerned about a large
coronavirus outbreak you have 56% in
Michigan 56% in Wisconsin 62 and a half
percent in Pennsylvania so people are
very concerned about this year however
they are not changing their plans so 79
percent of people in Michigan seventy
two point four percent of people in
Pennsylvania eighty-one percent of
people in Wisconsin say that they're not
planning to you know dramatically change
their lives for the wuhan virus and then
most importantly of all for our
political examination they think Trump
is doing a good job Trump has a net
positive approval rating on his handling
of coronavirus so far and it's a pretty
good buffer here in Michigan he's got a
net 15.6 percent positive approval
rating in Pennsylvania is eleven point
seven percent in Wisconsin it's seven
point five percentage points all that's
that's the net that's how much he's up
that's how much people like the way he's
responding to this now if you tuned in
to virtually any cable news program
right or left if you tuned in to the
pundits you would say oh he's messing
this up it's terrible what's he doing
stop doing is pulling your hair out well
guess what the voters in those key
states think he's doing a good job which
is all the more impressive because he
actually doesn't have a great overall
net approval rating his overall net
approval rating in Michigan is 2.9
points in Pennsylvania it's down 4.5
points and in Wisconsin it's down 4.5
points and yet on coronavirus people
think he's doing a good job so I
understand the in-depth analysis
historical precedent the esoteric
reading of the tweets I get it people
don't like it they think it's unseemly
when you've got a column in The New York
Times or when you've got a cable news
sure when you've got a podcast but for
voters on the ground at least according
to the one poll that we've got on it I
think he's doing a good job we will get
into more fake news going around about
President Trump because the press are
really attacking him now they've created
a new hoax they've got a new hoax about
from using the word hoax it's pretty
much like charlottesville 2.0 when Trump
allegedly called Nazis very fine people
even though that never happened we'll
get to that and we'll get to the woman
at Slate who's concerned that maybe her
husband should stop sleeping with his
girlfriend so that her mother doesn't
get coronavirus all that and much more
first I got to say about a Facebook and
YouTube right now we're offering 25% off
all daily wire membership plans when you
use the coupon code never socialist it's
important that you remember that code
just like it's important that Joe Biden
remembers his own name because we are
approaching the end of this offer and
you're gonna want to act fast you get a
ton of stuff election inside op-eds from
been exclusive access to ask questions
you get the bit leftist here's tumblr
that's going to be very important 25%
off daily wire membership for all plans
using coupon code never socialist head
on over to Daley wired.com slash
subscribe and remember this is the last
week that this deal will be available
might be the last week Bernie's in this
race so act now before it's too late the
other wire.com slash subscribe we'll be
right back
there is so much fake news going on
about Trump right now it's actually
distressing whatever legitimate
criticisms one could make of his
response in the last couple weeks are
just getting totally drowned out by all
the unfair attacks from the press how
about this one from Daily Mail us is the
headline you see it on Twitter Trump
refuses to say if he has been tested for
coronavirus and storms out of White
House briefing on crisis here's what
actually happened that is the slowest
storming out I've ever seen in my life
he is talking to the reporters he's
talking about coronavirus even says okay
thank you very much and then he very
slowly walks out which is the only way
that you could end any sort of press
conference and to the Daily Mail that's
he refuses to say if he's been tested
for Corona what and he storms out of the
White House briefing on the crisis they
can even include that first part cuz you
hear at the very end as he's walking out
the door here have you been tested he's
not at the podium anymore man he's not
he's already given it it's not like he
sprinted out typical right you see him
as I will 1 Mississippi 2 Mississippi 3
we said I would help out what a storm
now if Joe Biden were storming out
somewhere it might look like that but
you know Joe by there Donald Trump
rather is a young and vibrant man so if
you wanted the storm I'm sure he could
that's not even the biggest hoax the
biggest hoax right now being perpetrated
by the mainstream media is the hoax
about the hoax Democrats are now
accusing President Trump of calling the
coronavirus a hoax you see it it's all
over media it's all over cable news it's
and he called it a hoax it never
happened it never this is the new Nazis
are very fine people at charlottesville
hoax it's the hoax hoax it should be
obvious that President Trump does not
think it's a hoax because President
Trump appointed his number-two guy to
run the prevention and recovery if it
were a
he wouldn't have done that but here is
what President Trump said listen for
yourself how the Democrats are
politicizing the coronavirus you know
that coronavirus
they are politicizing it we did one of
the great jobs you say House President
Trump doing they go home not good not
good
they have no truth they don't have any
clue they can't even count their votes
in Iowa they can't even and this is
their new hoax but you know we did
something that's been pretty amazing
we're 15 people in this massive country
and because of the fact that we went
early we went early we could have had a
lot more than that we will do everything
in our power to keep the infection and
those carrying the infection from
entering our country we have no choice
so what's the hoax you have two options
here either the hoax that he's referring
to is the Democrats attacks on him for
not handling coronavirus well for for
botching the whole public health crisis
or the hoaxes coronavirus but it's
obviously the former how could the hoax
be coronavirus when Trump goes on to
brag about what a great job he did
stopping coronavirus and how had he not
acted as quickly as he had coronavirus
would have spread much more quickly and
there would be more deaths that was the
substance of his speech was man
coronavirus really could have been bad
but luckily I did a very good job at
stopping it and now the Democrats are
pushing this hoax
obviously the hoax is the criticism of
his response
you don't need an advanced degree to to
be able to understand that but the left
doesn't care I mean they're gonna push
it look they pushed in Charlottesville
the guy said on the issue of taking
statues down and to take away our
history they're very fine people on both
sides some people want to take take away
history some people want to keep history
I'm not talking about the neo-nazis and
the white supremacists who should be
condemned totally right that that was in
the next paragraph I guess it was in the
same paragraph just a few moments later
and what did the left say they said that
Donald Trump called neo-nazis very fine
people never happened put that away with
the Tooth Fairy and the Easter Bunny all
right not real and so they're doing it
here again not surprising could
president Trump speak different
like yeah yeah sure I sure I guess he
could that's the that is the criticism
of Trump baked into the equation from
the beginning he could talk different he
doesn't talk nice he tweets mean he uses
vulgar language he is very entertaining
and that's sort of unseemly in a
president yeah okay he could talk
different his president Trump's talking
costing people's lives in coronavirus
know are the tweets costing people's
lives in coronavirus know did Barack
Obama get anywhere near this kind of
scrutiny for the public health crises
that happen to under his administration
knew so how's he doing he's doing fine
media don't want to admit it but he's
doing he's doing fine speaking of
talking crazy speaking of crazy talk
slate slate magazine now that they
should have a recurring segment on this
show too because they and their Dear
Abby letters they always have the
strangest people write in and that's not
the big story here okay the letter that
they just published was should I pause
my open marriage because of the
coronavirus so it's not that they
published crazy letters you can always
find crazy letters and by the way a lot
of editors just write the letters
themselves
what makes this slate article so crazy
is the terrible advice that slate gives
so should I pause my open marriage
because of the coronavirus my mother is
immunocompromised you probably could put
the question mark up a few lines here
and just say should I pause my open
marriage question mark yes don't have an
open marriage close your marriage
marriage should be closed
there you go I solved it as I'm like one
sentence you don't even need the whole
article but they make it much more
complicated here the lady writing in
dear had to do it my husband and I have
an open marriage
my mother is immunocompromised is it
unreasonable to ask my husband not to
swap fluids with his girlfriend until
the coronavirus blows over risky
business yuck
the response is worse dear risky
business
blah blah blah so far I've yet to see a
public health official weigh in on
limiting one's exposure to his
girlfriend to be safe you could ask your
husband to do so also to be safe make
sure none of you leave the house for any
reason whatsoever where gas masks
constantly even in the shower even to
bed and apply hand sanitizer so often
that your skin is never not gleaming
with an alcoholic do or you could just
live your life and follow basic public
health advisories I suppose
mathematically your husband being in
close contact with another person does
increase his risk of contraction but
unless he and his girlfriend are into
public sex like in the middle of Times
Square public or our handrail licking
fetishists the elevated risk is probably
negligible swapping fluids seems like a
surefire way to pass or contract a virus
but if your mother lives with you but if
you don't need to get to the point of
not even say that on my show yuck gross
then here's the money line I am assuming
that you're operating on good faith and
not using this public health crisis as a
way to drive a wedge between your
husband and his girlfriend if that is
what you're doing please don't
everyone's got enough drama to deal with
as it is what a pervert what a jerk
what a creep writes this column because
you notice in the column the advice is
never hey be more traditional hey be
more virtuous hey acknowledge and follow
the moral order it's not what you get at
the college I was like yeah hell yeah
you should be sleeping with his
girlfriend and whatever I mean people
read these things to be titillated so
like that's fine I understand the
purpose of that column but let's just
assume that this is a real person
writing in with a real letter what what
a horrible thing to say to someone this
woman basically saying hey I've got some
I'm a little uncomfortable with my
husband's sleeping around and cheating
on me
so should we maybe tell him to stop that
and the person writing it says no what
are you crazy
what are you neurotic what are you
possessive ah no
oh excuse me we've all got enough to
worry about how dare you tell your
husband to stop cheating on his wife oh
what's wrong with you it's a terrible
thing to say to somebody horrible advice
from slate and it just shows you how how
depraved it all gets I mean this this
question at least is is not even posed
in a kind of I'm jealous that my husband
is cheating on me which any reasonable
person would feel it's posed as hey
there's a pandemic going on and I don't
want my mother who's got a frailty to
die because my husband wants to sleep
around so can I tell him not to and and
to be told no absolutely not I also love
its gives you away the whole game on on
the left here right the left on one hand
is say coronavirus is going to be the
end of the world it's all Trump's fault
the economy is going to tank everybody's
going to die you've got to take it
super duper uber seriously on the other
hand don't think for even one moment of
not slutting it up for a couple days
because of the infection on the one hand
oh no nothing could be worse you know
this Trump is killing us all on the
other hand yet go ahead and swap fluids
with anybody you meet on the street it's
no big deal stop worrying about it give
us away the whole game I mean they've
obviously politicized this beyond all
measure but terrible advice and I wish
that woman would write into my show so
that I could give her good advice on
this and shockingly I know this is gonna
come as a big surprise the slate advice
column is not the dumbest article on the
internet today it's not the dumbest
article on the Internet of our times the
dumbest article on the internet the
dumbest series and I haven't talked
about it much but I think the time has
come
is the 16:19 project from the New York
Times The New York Times is now
launching an initiative to convince
people that slavery is the essential
feature of America so America begins in
1619 when the first slave comes to the
colonies not 1620
when the Mayflower lands not 1776 when
you sign the Declaration of Independence
no slavery now you couldn't call this
project journalism for reasons we'll see
in a second you couldn't call it history
the the only thing you could call it and
this is actually the fairest term I can
come up with is propaganda
it has leftist propaganda decide to push
a narrative and people put out
propaganda all the time especially the
New York Times the reason that they're
catching a little bit of flak right now
is because actual historians and not
just conservatives leftist historians
too are criticizing the New York Times
and The Times will not hear that
criticism so Leslie Harris is a history
professor at Northwestern University
she's an author she just wrote a piece
in Politico about how she was approached
by the 16:19 project she gave her advice
she gave her notes on what the 16:19
project got wrong and the New York Times
completely ignored her so here's the New
York Times claim here's one of their
stupid claims quote one critical reason
that the colonists declared their
independence from Britain was because
they wanted to protect the institution
of slavery in the colonies which had
produced tremendous wealth at the time
there were growing calls to abolish
slavery throughout the British Empire
which would have badly damaged the
economies of colonies in both north and
south so that's that's like the one of
the far claims they can make is the
whole American Revolution the point of
it was to protect slavery now is that
true no historian Leslie Harris writes
in Politico quote I vigorously disputed
the claim although slavery was certainly
an issue in the American Revolution the
protection of slavery was not one of the
main reasons the 13 colonies went to war
the editor followed up with several
questions probing the nature of slavery
in the colonial era such as whether
enslaved people were allowed to read
could legally marry could congregate in
groups of more than four and could own
will or inherit property the answers to
which vary widely depending on the era
and the colony I explained these
histories as best I could with
references to specific examples but
never her
back from her about how the information
would be used despite my advice The
Times published the incorrect statement
about the American Revolution anyway in
Hana Jones's introductory essay so stuff
remember the first essay of 1619 in
addition the paper's characterizations
of slavery in early America reflected
laws and practices more common in the
antebellum era than in colonial times
that is the description the New York
Times is giving of these laws governing
slavery were much closer to what you saw
right before the Civil War and what you
saw during the founding error they just
got that the timeline completely wrong
she goes on they did not accurately
illustrate the varied experiences of the
first generation of enslaved people that
arrived in Virginia in 1619 right right
she never heard back how does the New
York Times do this how do you start a
project where you say we're going to
reveal the truth about American history
and then historians from across the
political landscape it's not just Harris
five other academic historians signed a
letter claiming quote that the 16:19
project got some significant elements of
the history wrong and The Times refuses
to correct the errors how do they get
that so dead wrong because they don't
care they don't care the people who
staff the New York Times are all a bunch
of over credentialed uneducated egotists
okay they're people who graduated from
very fancy schools and they're convinced
of their own brilliance but they don't
actually know much of anything and think
about it with regard to the gender issue
right let's say I we're gonna write a
devastating critique of gender roles in
the history of Western civilization so I
decide out of my own brain I'm not I'm
not reading anything I'm not learning
anything I just say you know one of the
big issues with gender roles is there's
actually 56 genders and you know for our
history we've pretended they're only two
genders but really they're 56 well what
would happen then a biologist would come
up to me and say oh no actually Michael
there there aren't 56 genders there
there are two right
because he would have some knowledge of
this topic and then he would tell that
to me and what would I say if I were a
leftist I would say what the leftists
are actually saying right now about that
very issue there's a nope sorry 56
because I said so it's the same thing
here they know nothing about the history
at the New York Times they know
absolutely nothing about the founding
era in the 16:19 project those writers
are absolutely wrong and profoundly
ignorant and yet they are convinced of
their own narrative there they're
convinced of the utility of their own
narrative where they just don't give a
damn it's important to remember this
this series is now being taught in
school districts in Chicago Washington
DC Buffalo in New York what does that
mean it means there's no objective press
in this country there isn't the gray
lady all the news that's fit to print is
publishing historical fiction in its
pages it means there's no objective
educational apparatus in this country in
some of our biggest cities we're
teaching this fiction as though it were
history
there is no objectivity in those
institutions for the transmission of
information the left is known this for a
long time
conservatives have been kidding
ourselves we always say we say when will
the press report on this well that shows
you how ignorant we are how we don't
learn the lesson we say when when's the
media gonna report on this thing that's
damaging to leftists they're not going
to ever ever not once okay get that
through your head once we accept that
once conservatives realize this is not a
level playing field this is not neutral
there is not a an even marketplace of
ideas that's that we can bandy about in
on the pages of the New York Times or in
our schools then and only then will we
begin to win the fight all right that's
our show I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Nolt show we'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director Havel
without ski editor and associate
producer Dany D'Amico audio mixer Robin
Fenderson hair and makeup
Nika Geneva production assistant Ryan
love the Michael Noel's show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20 if you prefer facts over feelings
aren't offended by the brutal truth and
he can still laugh at the insanity
filling our national news cycle well
tune into the Ben Shapiro show we'll get
a whole lot of that and much more see
you there